porque seguimos analizando los
resultados de la primera vuelta de estas
elecciones presidenciales en francia los
candidatos semana el macro animar inglés
en repite en la segunda vuelta tras su
del 2017 pero con condiciones totalmente
distintas los candidatos al inicio están
muy justos en las encuestas y micrón
tendrá que trabajar duro para lograr la
reelección además la abstención de esta
primera vuelta ha sido la más alta desde
el año 2002 por lo que la capacidad de
los dos candidatos para movilizar a los
electores que no los votaron será un
factor decisivo es que los candidatos de
izquierda y el ecologista sumaron un 31
punto 92 por ciento la orientación de
todo este voto puede ser importante y
determinante en esta segunda vuelta a
sus electores tienen que elegir entre la
tecnocracia liberal del candidato
presidente manuel macro y la
ultraderecha populista de marín lepén o
resignarse a no participar en esta
segunda vuelta todo puede pasar y para
analizar entonces qué puede pasar a cómo
están las cosas en este momento quiero
saludar a emilio ortiz él es periodista
de 20 minutos
del orden mundial especializado en
asuntos europeos gracias a emilio por
estar con nosotros en france 24 en
directo américa que va a pasar entonces
una revisión de esta segunda vuelta de
2017 que ha cambiado cómo ha cambiado el
país y también estos dos candidatos
bueno muy buenas a todos gracias por la
invitación por por resumir muy rápido no
lo que lo que está en juego en francia
en la segunda vuelta es ver si el
descontento de la sociedad es lo
suficientemente grande lo
suficientemente alto como para que
manuel mayo no repita como presidente
francés es básicamente el resumen y ahí
es donde buscará a marine lepén pasar a
ser la inquilina del elegido claro claro
y es que precisamente vamos a enfocarnos
en eso en esas encuestas que predicen un
margen de error muy muy estrecho entre
estos dos candidatos incluso y pop habla
de 51 49 a favor de macrón estamos
dentro del margen de error y porque
entonces estaba hecha tan reducida a
diferencia de más del año 2017 cuando no
fue así
bueno la brecha reducida entre los dos
candidatos se debe a varios componentes
no el primero como digo es ese
descontento ese desgaste que ha sufrido
un manual macro en los 25 años como
presidente pero también aquí en la
primera vuelta no ha hecho prácticamente
campaña electoral tuvo un solo gran acto
en parís hace más de una semana y a
partir de ahí a eso se agarra el
presidente que parece que va a cambiar
de estrategia de cara de cara al 24 de
abril pero es verdad que ya nadie nadie
habla de una diferencia tan grande como
la de 2017 que fue de más de 30 puntos
ahora eso no va a suceder el margen es
mucho más estrecho y por tanto macro lo
que en esa tendencia puede tener las de
perder será el que más se exigir o esté
en la segunda parte de la campaña emilio
hablaba de un cambio de rumbo y
estrategia en lo que sería la campaña en
estas dos semanas al 24 abril para la
segunda vuelta que debe hacer entonces
el presidente en el macro no para pues
digamos es tirar a la red y agrandar
esta brecha este estrecho margen con
marie le pen y que tiene que tiene que
hacer marie le pen para precisamente que
esta brecha no se alargue no sea grande
y pues repuntar y ganarle la presidencia
macro en el 24 abril
bueno realmente esto es relativamente
sencillo de resumir porque los dos
candidatos buscan lo mismo que es el
votante de jean luc mélenchon ese 20% de
la primera vuelta de del candidato de la
francia insumisa es un porcentaje lo
suficientemente alto como para que los
dos candidatos de la segunda vuelta se
disputen a su votante no es un votante
descontento es un votante pero
que no opta como primera opción por por
marine lepén ella en la noche electoral
hizo un llamamiento a unir fuerzas bajo
su candidatura imán cron necesita lanzar
algún guiño a ese votante más de
izquierdas más progresistas pero también
enfadados con él con el manuel macro
y tratar de convencerle de llevarle a su
terreno para que para que esa brecha se
alargue en su favor los dos se disputan
digamos ahora el mismo en el mismo nicho
de voto que es ese ese ese votante que
después de la primera vuelta corre el
riesgo de irse a la abstención que por
cierto es realmente alta sobre todo
entre los jóvenes hay que recordar que
uno de cada cuatro de cada diez jóvenes
perdón no han votado en primera vuelta
en francia eso es un porcentaje lo
suficientemente alto y yo creo que a
ellos van a apelar
tanto marín lepén como de manuel macro y
digamos estos jóvenes emilio van a votar
si en la segunda vuelta y también como
están las cosas esos esos votantes de
medición que quedó fuera de esta segunda
vuelta electoral se van a la fija con el
manuel macro no todavía no podemos decir
que se van con macro ni en esta segunda
vuelta digamos que no va a votar por
lepén definitivamente o puede que
algunos de ellos y voten por ella
es probable que haya un porcentaje de
ellos que sí que acaben votando a marine
lepén independientemente de que ayer
jean luc mélenchon insistió varias veces
en que no había que dar ni un voto a la
candidata de derecha radical pero el
verdadero en la verdadera duda con esos
votantes de jean-luc mélenchon es si van
a votar en segunda vuelta o se van a
quedar como abstencionistas en caso de
que voten lo ideal para macrón es que la
mayoría vaya hacia vaya hacia el no
pero no está del todo claro que ese
votante vaya a ir sí o sí al presidente
de la república al todavía presidente de
la república independientemente del
mensaje que dejase anoche
y anoche para nosotros en españa
halloween lección emilio hablemos de la
campaña que hizo la candidata de la
extrema derecha marine lepén ella
suavizó su discurso digamos que estaba
preparando el terreno para tener esta
brecha cerrada con el candidato
presidente emmanuel macrón lo hizo bien
la candidata en marín le pen y pues como
como podemos analizarlo
bueno realmente tú lo ha resumido bien
al principio se sea marín de pelo que ha
hecho ha sido disfrazarse de candidata
más moderada más con una imagen mucho
más presidenciable de su lema de campaña
ha sido un mujer de estado esas tres
palabras resumen bien sus intenciones y
se ha beneficiado también de la
aparición de eriksen
digamos que en el espectro de la de la
derecha radical o de la otra derecha
francesa la deja a ella como la
candidata más moderada en ese en ese
espacio no creo que ha jugado bien sus
cartas creo que ha sido capaz de que su
cercanía con vladimir putin en estos
tiempos de conflicto haya quedado en un
segundo plano casi nadie ha hablado de
sus vínculos de los vínculos del frente
nacional ahora agrupación nacional
con el kremlin que son por todos
conocidos de hecho incluso rusia
financió en su momento al partido de
marín de penn pero eso para su beneficio
no ha formado parte del debate y por ahí
ha sacado ha sacado ventaja a la
candidata